for more on the storm's path let's bring
in cbs news meteorologist and climate
specialist that's jeff baradelli jeff
good morning fill us in good morning
gail good morning everybody we had a
wind gust to 95 miles an hour last night
so we have lots of power outages but the
big story is the rainfall and it is
going to pile up during the day today so
let me show you the weather wall and
let's talk about where the heavy rain is
right now we'll bring up the radar over
the past six hours you can see it made
landfall about 40 miles to the southwest
of galveston now the heaviest rain right
here in the northeast corner of texas
and into southwestern louisiana all of
these bands two inch an hour rainfall
rates and the possibility of some
isolated tornadoes on the northeast side
during the day today there's a center of
low pressure look at this five out of
five flood risk in southwest southwest
louisiana but notice the dry air and
notice this wind shear coming in kind of
tearing the system apart you know and
pushing a lot of the moisture to the
east so that's going to limit rain
totals a bit but take a look at how much
rain that we expect to see i'm going to
bring this up right here this rainfall
is tremendous so we're talking about
anywhere from you know 8 to 12 inches of
rain across this area i'm going to push
this on over to the weather wall and
show you that heaviest rain really could
be anywhere from the mississippi coast
straight through new orleans they've had
two to three times the amount of normal
rain over the past you know couple of
weeks or so and that extends all the way
west towards port arthur and lake
charles so we're going to be dealing
with a pretty long day and some pretty
extensive flooding all right we'll get
through it thank you jeff